hire somebody that is the fundamental
answer to everything you're not good at
hire somebody that is good at it know it
well enough to know if they're doing it
well this portion is like with me so I
think this is one you need to get
selfish like you'd ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is know like
you gotta go fast that's how you get
[ __ ] done that's in figure stuff out
this is the television and the
television is the radio for forties
[ __ ] so at the three studios it
can't be everywhere all at once that's
right and it's really easy for me to get
the wind out of myself when someone when
one of the locations isn't delivering on
your standard it's the individual people
themselves right like crazy about this
I'm super super driven I know everybody
can be amazing and successful and they
just want to pay their bills so I'm
doing you're him you're you're your
employees yeah okay so a couple things
this is really funny cuz this is
probably the first thing I ever started
really talking to my dad about as a kid
as somebody who had like gifted wisdom
as like you know like you know like what
keeps me super like mellow is like my
thought process and like the things that
I do well are gifted DNA and
circumstances so I never get high on my
own supply
cuz that like it's just so weird that
this was probably the first thing I
started talking to my dad about when I
was 15 years old I look at my dad one
time we were driving and I said dad if
they were you they wouldn't work for you
this is something we talked about 28
years later my dad brings up that
statement because he's like you were a
kid like your ideology for what
everybody should be doing is the
quickest way for you to struggle there's
a very big dip like like I have enormous
you know energy on like impacting people
in a good way whether it's directly
attributed to the people that work with
me or the masses whether that's through
heart or hustle or whatever it may be
but but you have to become deeply aware
that there's only so many things you can
handle the other thing that it really
leads to is it leads into you trying to
control something you can't which then
takes this compounds and like takes over
it's it's it's a losing proposition
first of all there's a lot of
there's a lot of bad in it there's a lot
of ego and a lot of your own [ __ ] that
you need to like really understand that
truth like it's the same bad that I have
I create entitlement because I try to
take on too much on myself you know and
so like there's you got to be careful
with this one here's what I would say
your job as somebody that sits at the
top of something is to put players in
the best position to succeed once you've
done that you've got to allow them to do
their thing you're a capitalist trying
to deploy almost socialist communist
ideology you can't control everything
like there's nothing wrong with paying
what's wrong with paying your bills says
who you don't know them you don't know
them I know I know Caleb solidly I know
Nick solid like you don't know you're
[ __ ] your [ __ ] spouse and parents
don't know you right let's get to like
real talk there's not a single percenter
that actually knows you every single
person has certain little subtle things
that they still have not articulated to
the world to not one person it's not
you're being ideological to scratch your
own itch you have to understand that I
think a bigger thing is where are you
going with that right I think if you're
going into a place of like they could be
so much more and we can win together
which would make sense to me right you
let me help you be a better employee
you'll do better will do bit right
you're better off firing them me too me
too but MA me hating firing people
creates what I do with it is I create
entitlement and protect people at my
cost which makes them think they're
better than they are
Joran you're not firing people is you're
imposing an ideology on them you're
making it about you could be so much
you're putting it on them instead of
yourself you don't want to fire them
because they're not capable of over
delivering or delivering on this
and of what you need for your business
and so the way you're deploying that
resentment is deploying them to feel bad
that they're not achieving their
capability predicated on something that
you need them to do in the context of
your four walls I'm at my best when I
fire fast when I know it's wrong and I
do that rarely because I don't like it
but I've gotten better at it but you
shouldn't create you know you know
you're putting you know resentment comes
out in very different ways when I'm
resenting something I'm razzing people
like I'll make jokes that's my way of
getting it out you're not doing any
favours looking somebody dead in the eye
and say you could be so much more that's
doing nobody a favor you're not it's not
doing you a favor it's not doing them a
favor what you need to be thinking about
is first and foremost the number one
thing you need to be thinking about is
the three managers or the one regional
manager the people that are actually
responsible in the trenches
that's who needs to be a hundred you fix
that you fix everything don't focus on
the sink focus on the well everything
I'm worried about in the thousand
employees here is predicated my 11
direct reports that run those
departments got it
the managers if the three managers are
perfect then you'll be set no [ __ ] I
know I know that's how it works that's
how businesses work you've only got two
variables and that you're talking about
this is why it's easy for me to
understand I know they're not right and
then underneath that the employees you
have either they're underperforming
because the manager blows and you know
it or they just been around for a while
and you have actual human emotion to
them and those are both valid but the
quickest thing that will make you so
much happier is to make sure the three
managers are phenomenal yep three Otis
oom per location
and if anything goes wrong you've
created that just like I created here
you need to uncreate that and what is
fine at a smaller business level and so
I worked for me at Wine Library is when
it's smaller there's a level of fine but
if you have ambition and for it to grow
you need to you know you need to get the
value out of the way you're compensate
you're better off compensating more and
letting people do the defense in the
[ __ ] as well so it's a target market I
appreciate I think that as long as
you're authentic you know there is a
small subset and any subculture there's
always a part of that group that will
always be like well you're not one of us
so you have no permission here but if
you speak to admiring something as long
as you're clear cut about that and not
hiding and trying to avoid I think I
think you'd be surprised on how much of
a non-issue that is for the eighty nine
percent because the eleven percent and
and that's and the consumer is always
right
like you can't focus on that you give
two moves you're more than welcome to
make a video and be like look I have
deep admiration for our law enforcement
and our military and here's why and I'm
extremely proud that we make our product
in America and we have competitors in
the marketplace who've been in the space
but they make their product in China and
you the customer should decide I would
because that's how I roll you don't need
to but you
I'm not a big fan of dwelling without
action either you never dwell about it
again or you mention it but the middle
blows that's what you're doing like like
that's the game that the reason I don't
complain like like like the reason I
genuinely don't is I've got a very basic
thesis either I do something about it or
if I've decided I don't want to do
something about it which is many things
I don't do so there's certain things
that cross places where I'm not
comfortable when I keep my mouth shut
cuz there's too much energy wasted and
dwelling your competitor has you on
defense I spend I know nothing about my
competitors the consumers the only thing
that matters I just don't care the whole
like you you can learn from them like
I'll learn it anyway plus I'm not
worried about the past this is what's
great about being in the trenches right
having a rest like I have come to learn
that growing up in a liquor store and a
baseball card table my whole life was
I'm behind something somebody's coming i
watch what they do something happens
consumer the end so yes I would because
I would like to create the conversation
of that because I think it's a
competitive advantage especially if
they're not authentic about it because
then you can get you know people are
very curious you put it out there people
start digging they find right in a
podcast the other day I mentioned that I
was in WrestleMania I showed up in this
WrestleMania and I said I was once in
another WrestleMania I got the clip now
somebody found it people dig people dig
you set it up let somebody else make the
expose if you don't want to go all the
way there anyone knowing is fun that's
what I would do I'd put out the clipping
be like here we are
and Iowa making the chitwa I don't what
do you make the chips great here we are
Bay Area making the chips be fun to see
our competitors show where they make the
chips
everybody knows what you're saying yes
my story's similar to yours my first
business card was when I was 12 my
sister do you know my hole do you know
what's happening with these sports cards
suck dude on a very serious I cannot
believe what's happening I'm like
freaking out it's coming back it's about
to happen
anyway nonetheless so cool I grew up in
so cool I wanted to be the first in the
yellow pages
yes you know that by the way do you guys
know that that's why so many companies
are named ABC the yellow pages was in
triple-a the yellow pages were so
important the Google of their day you
wanted to be first and the way you
hacked it was by being triple-a cool
right
my curse that I used to think that I was
like maybe we should rebrand ah liquors
like when I was a kid because I realized
hacks like came naturally nonetheless
never changed it but over the years I
okay so I don't know if I should beat
that still 55% of the business is poker
would you say I should combine all and
start maybe ABC poker or something why
that's the most important stone fragment
for who for you on the back end for the
consumer for us so for the consumers
what do you think happens do they know
that they're even associated the
question is doesn't matter and then what
are you trying to accomplish you know
like you know to me the reason the
consolidate is you've got a big
commitment to building a brand and that
when you flip it there's gonna be a
delta on the brand value right so when
you sell a business or when you value a
business there's the ebody of like
here's the profit and then there's a
thing above it which is what's the brand
worth right the reason to consolidate is
to build a brand I would not call it ABC
I would create a brand right that would
be the biggest reason to consolidate in
my opinion based on what you're saying
then then there's no crazy reason other
than maybe you just want to manage one
site maybe you're curious and what its
gonna mean maybe there are some
curiosities of like but like you know if
you think about it I assume these are
web-based driven businesses right you're
gonna give up notion and you're not
giving me a compelling reason to if
you're gonna give up all that SEO juice
all that brand equity all the people
that and I'm gonna guess 80% don't give
a [ __ ] or know that you have seven other
sites and now you're gonna consolidate
them all and they're gonna you know like
type in what you know pom whatever and
it redirects to this I know what but
then it's like that's not my stood let
me tell you a great story about Wine
Library we built a new store on the same
[ __ ] plot of land and everybody
decided was a different store and that
we were more expensive and we dropped
prices
people don't like change the second you
redirect their names like this is
somebody bigger bought my people and now
it's more expensive we're not as good
you know I just don't see the value
unless you've got a strategy for it you
know what I mean this makes sense
welcome okay
yeah really Jimmy is the app this is
like listen we're here right like let's
do it you're trying to change other
people's opinions of it this is a very
important starting point and it's not
easy anywhere just you know like let's
yeah good news it's not an Alaska thing
it's a human thing humans are really
good at putting the past on a pedestal
and demonizing the current very good at
it yeah reputation small it's very it I
love it it's very easy I'm gonna give
you really good advice disproportionate
honey on top of vinegar so we've decided
that Sally's hair salon has gotta go
she's grandfathered in at a rate that we
no longer can deal with she's
disproportionately time-consuming in
return for the ROI
but she's massively lovely it's no
different than firing somebody you know
what my advice to people who struggle
with firing give huge severance it works
let me play it out for you we're all
playing the same game ready
you don't like firing somebody give them
four months severance where most people
just fire them and they have to go on
the street I promise you you're gonna
sit on firing them for more than four
months now you're Mother Teresa and
you've solved your problem a hundred
percent
you're not valuing the money isn't as
valuable as that you being on defense is
so expensive you telling somebody look
we're going in a little bit of a
different direction I'm giving you a
six-month Head Start I will help you
hire a different agency or hire somebody
I'll interview them it amortizes out you
feel great about you and you solved the
problem in a way that's disproportionate
honey on top of vinegar it is good it is
good it's good it's good because I'll
tell you why it's good because I'm a
successful businessman who does that I
understand it I don't keep it what's so
fun for me about giving advice is I only
give advice I know and like I know this
move works for a certain type of
individual for my dad it's the stupidest
things I've heard just walks in goes
you're fired we're done with you Sally
that's how he rolls he's cool like that
and that's amazing that's a strength
that I don't have I have my
disproportionate honey with vinegar
nobody gives [ __ ] two months
severance in the tattoo parlor business
so even if they and by the way sometimes
I've given disproportion honey with
vinegar like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
even when I've done things that make no
sense but about three years later they
come back and like actually in hindsight
now that I've lived on the grass is
greener you're actually extremely nice
thank you for that that's what you do
with clients you'd fire them in a way
that's amazing for them
once you recognize it you go into how do
I solve this issue yeah you you make
them part of the process you walk and
say this is not working for our business
anymore you tell the truth
like we're evolving and it's you know
the time allocate we only you know I can
only I only have so many hours in a day
and the business requires this and so
but I don't want you to have collateral
damage from this decision in the short
term so let's put together a six-month
strategy we can we're happy to stay on I
will try just as hard if not harder I
tell people what I'm doing okay I tell
them I tell people what I'm doing
sometimes please our business has
changed our business has changed that's
not your fault
we're so grateful that you signed up
with us a year ago let me help make the
next six months transition awesome
including helping you hire the
replacement or helping you hire somebody
internal to do sorry doing what we do
it's honest
yeah because because anybody once you're
half pregnant the great back to giving
the advice that I gave you like my ego
of I can't fire this kid he doesn't have
a college degree this is now Wine
Library Talk I do it here where kids can
get jobs we have a great job market
right now they've worked at Bainer even
now they have a nurse [ __ ] in there
LinkedIn they they're more than capable
and I'm still like but there it was like
they here it's easy there it was
impossible I was building up kids who
like had no other leverage in life
besides the fact that they've been with
me for two years and it wasn't so easy
to replicate cuz Wine Library was at the
top of a small thing so I wasn't they go
to another liquor store and get that
much but that was my ego talking every
kid that I thought could not survive in
the world
without me went on and got another job
and survived plenty and some did better
yes I think that's all you got to do it
will work yeah so so my question is kind
of like before that yep before we get to
clients so we like you said that happens
everywhere right when we're talking to
people and we can show them case studies
or we could show them whatever maybe we
have four meetings with these people
potential client or a lead and we're
showing them all these things is there
anything other than case studies are
showing them actual work that you did -
no no and where do you draw that line of
like trying to earlier than you have
been yeah the bet the thing I'm best at
is bailing quick I don't try to sell
unsellable people so let me do that
topic well please tell them you get them
on now they're on with you you've had
the whole thing yep great we have a
client like this and yep good I'm ready
now we're in the dirt yeah okay here's
the game plan here's how ya move and now
they're totally pulling back and not
allowing us that's all time to us - I
call them as the CEO sometimes and say
look you hired vaynermedia and now
you're trying to make us act like
Ogilvie I go you should just hire
Ogilvie and then they have to make a
decision you have to be willing to walk
or do what they say and by the way we're
happy like I can't get to everybody in
this company the size that we're in
we're doing what they say in place
plenty places there's not a single
client at vaynermedia that does exactly
what I want them to do not one not one
yeah I'm just not ideological
I've points of view I'm very comfortable
articulating them but I don't have full
say they're paying me I'm in the client
service business
yeah I mean that's right I think you're
I think the one thing that will make a
lot of sense to you I'm very comfortable
doing what a client's forcing me to do
since they're putting my dad I've been
bringing my dad a lot which is fun
my dad has a had a great on that like
there's this great great Russian saying
that he would always like bring up
because it was his leverage but like I
heard my uncles say and but like it's a
classic Russian saying you know like
whenever American sayings we have it's a
whoever pays for the music gets to pick
the song and I [ __ ] love it
like we don't have a like I don't know
the American like they're so you know
how that's what's great about knowing
other languages there's some great like
I love clearly I love analogies and
things I love that one that's how I
think about being a medium they're
paying here's the one thing that you
should do though you should die on your
own sword
meaning no problem big client we're
happy to do it I just want to remind you
that it is our strategy to do this I do
that a lot
yes right you're like yes thank you
yeah beggars can't be choosers there's a
good American yeah we're starting to get
it's a process yeah let them know where
you're set you were your strategy set
that's important it's important
yeah I think I think the reason that
works for me and I think it's something
that I recommend is I just don't think
about it yeah I think people think
there's try to overthink it
you know like live your life like you
you know it's it's a similar to the
advice I gave you there's a lot of
people that wouldn't have given the
advice that I just gave you the business
book ideology is consolidated there's a
lot of people that are giving you advice
about your personal brand and your
businesses that went to business school
and are executives and companies and
they give advice the reason I love this
session this part is I get to give you
contextual advice after you've been
watching higher level theoretical advice
for a while I listen right and then I
answer so like you know people like Gary
this is the favorite of every smart
person I know Gary what happens to
Boehner if you get hit by a bus and I go
it goes out of business and they're
flabbergasted they're like what's your
contingency plan I'm like life insurance
like what do you mean I'm like when I
die if I died by a car accident right
now it's really awesome that I bought so
much life insurance based on my
potential earnings that my family will
at least achieve some percentage of that
ROI which I'm not even that pumped about
because I'm on a new kick I'm not giving
my kids anything let alone
like I'm not a whole different I used to
make fun of Warren Buffett and Bill
Gates forgiving alike because I come
from immigrants like
you give your Fayette like right I was
like [ __ ] those [ __ ] now I'm
like they're brilliant your kids are
losers like on day one if you give them
too much anyway nonetheless I say to
them it goes out of business
and they're flabbergasted like bro let
me and then I go into like and usually
these are non entrepreneurs giving
advice I go let me tell you something
about Nike and Amazon and Puma and Chase
Bank it is far more likely that the CEO
of coca-cola turns every six seven years
than me getting hit by a bus and the
second it does that company changes
forever like I don't care what happens
to vaynermedia when I'm dead I'm pissed
them died you know how to mean like like
like people are so confused so anyway
back to this answer blend them play what
when a company comes to try to buy it
they're gonna want you there for three
years anyway and lock you in to be the
executive that hands it off anyway and
so whatever personal brand equity you
have you're gonna be able to trade on at
best guess what when you leave after
three years you'll still have your
personal brand and start your next [ __ ]
ice moved very seamlessly from wine to
marketing and I'll move very seamlessly
from marketing to sports car dealer you
know hire somebody that is the
fundamental answer to everything you're
not good at hire somebody that is good
at it know it well enough to know if
they're doing it well got it correct
just enough sales is easy I've hired you
I have a set expectation of what I pay
you and what I kind of to have a feel
for my business that's easy somebody do
your social media marketing when you
have no idea about social media is hard
you don't even know what they're doing
got it know it well and I'm what makes
me super interesting I think is I'm
dangerous enough in everything that my
company does but I don't need to be the
best at it I'm just the best at the
holistic version of it
I don't think anybody in my company can
beat me one-on-one but a lot of people
can have better skills within the sub
cultures of the craft that whole like
what's that brother thank you happy to
do it
happy to do it brother the whole like I
don't even really know what a
Renaissance man is but I think when
people throw it at me on social they
talk about like you do a lot of things
that I'm like thinks seems practical
yeah you know like seems practical when
you own a business for you to be
dangerous enough to know everything so
that you don't become vulnerable people
sometimes say I don't deal with my
finances I'm like you're in trouble you
have a business
I don't like finances at all I [ __ ]
know this is literally I just sign
everything everything my lawyers and my
team puts before I don't have but like
you have to know it enough yet that
least understand basic like do I make
more money than I lose every time like I
have a great CFO Alan and he loves to
like I'm so offense he's like so much
more discipline he Raz's and sometimes
he likes to allude to like he's the
grown-up and I laugh and I'm like bro
I've been in business for 20 years in my
life I've made every payroll in my life
it's Street [ __ ] family business I may
not like I do not know the tax law the
way you do that could maximize some of
our opportunities and I'm pumped and
that's my pay you will fuckload of money
but I make my payroll you know you just
got to be basic shit's basic business is
basic the reason I'm so cynical to the
current state of entrepreneurship is we
have students in business now business
is basic
we're we're having a play here it's
going really well
good we're about to be growing in size
and your partners have ambitions for it
to be a national product franchise model
or your own no cliche you were stretched
too thin when you focused
it worked yeah yeah when things fail
it's very obvious to look backwards and
be like right I'm a big fan of pulling
in and pulling back out in theory Yeah
right
in theory the del the Delta between the
things I like the most the things like
the things I like the most and the
things I'm best at I keep and the things
I don't like and the things I'm not best
at I try to systematically give away
over time self-awareness and happiness
is the answer to your question there's a
shirt like what are we doing here like
you have a business like to do what you
like [ __ ] it if you can't like you many
people build a business that then the
business eats them and it becomes a job
and like the thing you like didn't want
to do like everybody else or the thing
you ran away from becomes the thing with
the added pressure and loneliness of
entrepreneurship so the things I like
and the things I'm best at you know
but there isn't I love shredding
everything back in like you also hone
your skills and then you get better at
judging the people you bring in the next
time all of a sudden your email
marketing head is not gonna be able to
trick you that they suck because you
know MailChimp I love that feeling I
love it you know firing firing money
where your mouth is
culture is easy if you're willing to
fire people that produce money that are
[ __ ] good firing so so so to me with
that firings way more important way more
because hiring is guessing firing is
knowing I used the way I hire like when
I'm like left to my vices like cool yeah
interested come on yes there's nothing
better than firing somebody who's
cancerous in culture it sets the tone it
builds confidence I'm very big on that
and then just articulating it I mean
every day people come in here like into
my office or Gary like you know people
love [ __ ] theoretics Gary what are we
doing here I'm like I put out content
every I mean every day I've articulated
that we're building a machine that sells
[ __ ] so I can buy a bracelet like it's
like like like it's the most like it's
crazy people have made over six years
they'll walk in sometimes oh they carry
you know feel like we've lost our way
here at Vayner like what are we doing
here I'm like and I literally go into
like Gary me mode not Gary Vaynerchuk
the exact I'm like all right well we're
building a marketing machine to Tuhoe my
skills and meet people and train you
guys up
and then the economy's gonna collapse
and I'm gonna buy puma or k-swiss or
Hershey's we're gonna run it through and
they're like like it's like I've been
very consistent here that's what we're
doing here I've been right Jessie like
it's been super consistent but like but
like people people love to like people
love to like pontificate and you're it's
why I hate the advice that you guys get
from not I'm gonna say something that I
genuinely believe anytime an ngon actual
operating entrepreneur friend of yours
gives you advice you should look him
dead in face and go you have no idea
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
it's it's why I like have gotten really
quiet you know one of the things I'm
most proud of is I talk about the same
[ __ ] in my content because I'm not
willing to go to places where I'm not
willing to go anymore I don't know what
it's like in those other places like I
have theories
I have hypothesis but until you walk
into man's shoes you just don't know
right so an especially entrepreneurship
it's just you know it's all people
talking theory it's what it's what gets
people that are too socially liberal in
trouble and I'm socially liberal as [ __ ]
but like everything's great in theory
now go execute it
go read communism it's amazing no really
go read Marxism like it's super it like
I want it just doesn't it's now humans
work and that's how I think about
business cool yeah
you shouldn't micromanage that's nice
you're going to a job tomorrow that's
gonna pay you I have to go in here and
be like the last line defense of my
business and right now nobody's doing
email marketing and I haven't hired
anybody do it so I'm gonna do it like
you know what I mean we're in limbo at a
cheap strategy with our chief strategy
officer left like last week on family
reasons so we're interviewing so she's
not here I when we did Sasha assume the
CEO Oh roles from James source so I'm
the CEO CEO Oh CSO I guess for all-in
types of purses though I'm not you know
like absent flows I'm gonna hire
somebody am I gonna like you know like
herbs and flows by the way there's
another one talk to people once you have
a feel of what every person wants and
once you create a place that's safe for
them to tell you the truth you got a
prayer and take it from somebody's
really trying it's super hard they'll
tell you I sent out [ __ ] emails like
once every three months with a video of
me like come took literally the video I
did last Friday right was it I was like
if you think that if you came and told
me your boss is a [ __ ] then I would
fire you or you're in trouble you don't
know where you work
yeah that's the biggest fear of every
person that works here humans but the
one thing I can control is what I do so
even though I know that 80% won't act it
doesn't stop me from putting out the
content in company-wide emails once
every couple months whenever I feel
inspired right I keep pounding it and
then people that are here for five and a
half years will go through something and
then I'll get on the phone with them
they're like yeah and I'm like why don't
you come and talk to me and like yeah
didn't you okay so the local thing I got
it you need to change that vendor right
anybody you're paying that isn't willing
to give you clean information is a
problem okay
period always yep what about taking it
internal you should taste them you
should try it okay it's yes it's smart
of you and I don't you notice how like I
don't like to do absolute answers but
based on multiple times just learning
what it looks like what it feels like is
a good context point because when that
doesn't work then you can step back and
be like okay this doesn't work that
doesn't work like or what it works like
[ __ ] I should have done this all along
you just need a context point there's so
many things I do that I actually don't
think are gonna work but I do them
because I need the reference point
that's actually how I built all of a
nemedia most of what I did at
vaynermedia 20 19 18
most of what I did in vaynermedia from
20 15 16 and 17
I didn't
believe it fully but I needed the
context point of what big agencies look
like and I need to do it within my own
four walls and now I'm unraveling it
this is getting good
those are garbage they're most likely
they are yeah cuz that's what it was
supply and demand issues the the [ __ ]
1980
baseball let's start with baseball 1982
to 2002 like nineteen to that like 1999
to Mike Trout time to like like all the
stuff from like 82 like 2000 isn't a bad
place baseball too much supply not
enough demand but like 8687 flea or
basketball gold cuz it was all cuz
basketballs culture now like nobody
wants a Tony Gwynn rookie card nobody
wants Wade Boggs nobody wants that
people want Jordan
culture culture basketball one
baseball's declining then that was too
much supply it's just supply demand
honestly that's why I understand what's
about to happen I'm really good at
supply and demand and I know that the
demand for sports cards is about to
really go enough to make it move against
the supply got it
I think basketball sink rep I think
basketball is gonna be incredible I
think China's gonna get involved and
when that happens just think about
Asia's money for Jordan rookies LeBron
rookies Kobe rookies Steph rookies it's
about to happen
global it's a global sport and I think
the the sneaker thing with kids like you
know like it's cumbersome these sneaker
kids first of all you can't get as many
off whites and Yeezys and like limited
edition Nikes as you want even when you
were right you're like that's gonna be
good like the you know the fear of God
collab is gonna work so you can't get
enough inventory where is like it
you make a hot take right now and Jason
Tatum and you think he's really gonna be
the guy you can go buy 50,000 rookie
cards you know yeah I think cards are
not to explode I think I'm really I'm
like I can't believe it's happening
actually the Fed like my life is getting
so weird I started a wine brand I'm
getting to come I'm going backwards you
know feel like an old man you know like
my like it's what happens but ya know I
think it's gonna happen
marketing real quick because I wanna
bring you value you guys do what cold
calling Direct Mail Google AdWords I
think you should really focus on
Facebook
the older demo if you were referring to
that are you going after all older he's
going anyhow right how are you getting
business now word-of-mouth yep you know
you're doing you're in a referral
business yeah this is what I hate about
services for real life they all let all
these companies that got in front in
between Google and them homeadvisor
Zillah
OpenTable in the restaurant world what's
that and it's all the same [ __ ] you need
that's what happened like just to give
you a quick punchline of what happened
in the world Google I was right about
Google AdWords I did a nice job and
built my dad's liquor store there was
much smarter people than me that build
platforms that sat in between Google and
the business underneath them and that's
who built huge huge companies right you
got to get out of that you can't be
reliant on somebody who's a tollbooth
what if they said the price is double
you're gonna pay you have no leverage
whoever's whoever's closest to the
customer wins when Amazon raises Prime
by 40 bucks next year you're gonna say
thank you so much when Netflix raises
Netflix by 6 bucks
whoever's closest and bringing the most
value to customer wins
you can't be in a referral based
business your sucker yeah I'm fine with
that but you're still in you're
basically in intent-based transactional
sales mode and I want you to be the
authority you're marketing to a local
area right put out a video every day of
how people should be maintaining their
homes I think every service provider
should put out content of how to people
on Facebook of how not to have to use
them I believe in that the most I
believe it the most it's my number one
thesis I believe in it do you know any
mechanics make money on something that
you could have changed a spark plug for
I'll give you a person that would fall
for it every time I have no concept of
how a car works I'm completely baffled
by the modern automobile just don't know
give us [ __ ] I take no Kyle of when
people like my buddies like you're not a
man I'm like [ __ ] you like how much
money do you have you know like like you
know what's the definition of a man you
know like cool I don't have to change my
car I'm like I have enough money to have
multiple people change it I'll buy a new
[ __ ] car like does it work I'll buy a
new one like you know like you know
whatever like everybody has their own
skin but like I think you want to build
trust hey I talked to a roofer friend
I'm like hey you need to put out content
every day the stuff people should be
doing to maintain their roof so they
don't have to pay you 30,000 or 8,000
you know and they've been doing it it's
working
Facebook Facebook make content run ads
against people in the neighborhoods that
you're trying to reach it'll show up in
there okay Facebook ads on Facebook
where you know exactly what you're
saying against who you're saying it to
give me the bit your best town yeah that
you do business in that's the name of
the town great you make a video hey
Granada Hills it's me
I'm servicing a lot of you I want to
service less of you let me explain so
many of you are paying me five ten
thousand dollars to do X but if you
actually spend $130 a month doing this
less of you would need me that is a
single best thing you could ever do for
your business
guys I learned this from Wine Library TV
this is horrible do not buy this I'm
selling it people are watching like what
the [ __ ] is this guy up to I wasn't even
sure I just subconsciously knew that if
I was good for the customer that'd be
good for me it wasn't good for this we
were gonna have a trouble selling this
now but in the macro I was building a
relationship I'm giving away all my
marketing advice for free so you don't
have to like right to the point where
look at how many this is it's all free
but you're here paying trust was built
then I get even more scared I'm like
[ __ ] to come in they're paying we have
to make this awesome the stuff that
you've the reason you reacted even after
seven years of like awesome is like what
we've done so far and you know like it's
valuable because you're at a big enough
business scale what was smart about 40 s
was pricing it expensive enough so that
people that were coming through weren't
hoping and dreaming and it's not a
lottery ticket
means you're far enough along to get a
singular piece of advice that can make
the arbitrage of $12,000 worth it got it
that's how it clicked makes sense then
you make it a apologize then you make it
a phone call ad if you go older I like
the phone ads reap a content but there's
a phone number then they just click it
right from there it was a huge missed
opportunity for you huge you didn't make
an impact in culture because they left
on their terms not you firing them huge
mess I mean it
give that thought to like everybody else
I know you don't run the whole company
she didn't she won the game you guys
lost I'm devastated when that happens at
Boehner at Vayner when I'm like there's
people that are fired at Vayner right
now in my head but it might take me
three and a half months to make it
happen for a magnitude of reasons
occasionally that person will quit and
I'm devastated because I wasn't able to
through my actions to show the rest of
the company that we know that that
person wasn't right people know
everything she got ahead of you guys
she won your employees don't know that
they don't believe you a hundred percent
she controlled she controlled the
narrative missed opportunity but still a
good net positive but it's something to
think about and I know that you don't
ball the control I remember kind of the
narrative from the sneaker thing
whatever but like just I'm kind of back
to like what I'm trying to do here it's
advice for everybody else it's it's for
people that don't like to have fire it's
the double damage because they have the
narrative they control it I'm out of
this [ __ ] they were to cancer they
know that they're not on point with you
so they got ahead of it and then they
tell everybody I'm leaving this [ __ ]
place this place always suck I leave and
they have all the leverage got it I know
I'm right correct and then you have
collateral damage
yep yep yep yep you got it you got to
always control the narrative it's I'm
telling you it's notice how I reacted
it's like one of my most difficult
things running this Co because sometimes
there's reasons not to fire somebody
whether it I got a transition a client
whether they're one of the biggest
reasons I don't fire clients is I have
to build equity with the three or four
people around them because they've
already been doing cancer and I got a
syphon the equity to me before I fire
them yeah Sally [ __ ] her crew is being
manipulated by Sally
I like that crew and there's a lot of
great people I've got to spend two
months between me and other managers to
build equity with them so they
understand Sally's garbage and then you
get rid of Sally because if you get rid
of Sally before then they leave too it's
like it's the most funny thing ever it's
like parents remember all the [ __ ] you
thought your parents didn't know but
then you got older and I got [ __ ] new
you were jumping out the window and
hooking up with Rick you're like [ __ ]
mom how'd you know cuz you know I love
when my employees think I don't know I
[ __ ] know everything no but right
right Nick like like like that was like
an evolution right it's interesting
right yeah you're super on it but like
anyway that's not your question go ahead
20:21 I had a good time good think about
it yes it got me thinking of more ideas
good to know so I was like man I can
feel the machine here really well as a
company but then look we got it we
started interviewing content creators
and I want to know like when it comes to
the best Roger I don't know the best way
to figure out where I was going I know
there's a few companies like carvanha
they're like get rid of like a new way
to find say fart smells like will just
be the car buy it but we'll just
strictly by and we a full sellout our
cars will sell in franchise dealerships
but is that just first like should I be
thinking more of how can I
everyone in called dealerships or hey is
this words tr3 auto dealerships are
going to be around for minimum ly
another decade because you haven't seen
enough transition happen yet
let's start with that meaning like
you're not seeing car dealerships
clothes all the time you're not seeing
Ford announced that they're not gonna do
tier 3 anymore there hasn't been
anything that's happened and even when
Ford says we're gonna not do dealerships
anymore it's gonna think in five years
because there's deals in place so I
think a lot of times people see the
future but don't realize how long it
takes I made that mistake in 1998 I
decided when I came back with launched
996 I start running the company in 98
the store and I decide by the year 2000
it was 18 months this is what's so funny
about being a kid you'd think eighteen
months is like a million years you know
I'm like by the year 2010 more wrong
by the year 2000 everybody will come
into my wine store and scan every
barcode because I made up that phones
would have scanners on them by then and
and they'll know the price of every wine
and I'm gonna have to lower the price
and be the lowest price and everything
cuz I I still to this day don't know
when you sell when you sell a service
you can talk about it from a service
standpoint I still don't know how to
explain to somebody if I sell a bottle
of wine why somebody else selling it
cheaper why they should buy it for me I
do not understand and I never did and
that
why Wine Library had the best prices on
every [ __ ] wine in America when I ran
the store because I don't understand
what the answer to that question is and
so I lowered the prices of every single
product crushed our margin but it never
happened we still don't have it and and
that's how I that's how I've gotten good
if you notice I know a lot of you guys
follow I'm so much more right than
everybody else about VR 24 months ago
when everybody was talking about it
right everybody said right everybody was
all freaked getting fired up and I was
like it's not even close and here we are
24 months later and still nothing has
happened not even the beginnings of
something same thing that's happening
with machine learning
nai right now everyone's talking about
it every day and I'm like that's cool
and there's a lot more going on there
but the things that people say it's
going to do or 13 years from now so yes
do I think cars are going direct to
consumer yes I do do I think it's going
to take a decade to three I do the end
and I think youngsters who are
progressive could get caught on the
timing of innovation got it I think that
you are because you haven't lived
through a couple cycles are gonna see
things that are right because you're
digitally native you're younger you're
coming from a different perspective
it's gonna take longer than you think
for it to materialize I believe that
online dating was gonna be mainstream in
1998 it really probably I mean match.com
at some level but like tinder in 2012 or
I'm trying to think now like it took a
long time but I knew it would happen but
nobody believed me what happened it's
like sports cards right now it's already
happened I know what's gonna happen most
people are like looking at me like oh
you just cuz you liked it when you were
like they don't see it yet
where do you go do you have control so
they are open for bus and we talked
about hey should we fix everything first
and then ask for money or well first can
you make money instead of asking for it
or no can you make more I got it look I
think raising capital on your terms and
your advantage is a good idea I don't
think that's how it ends up most times
whoever's asking for the money has less
leverage so I'm a big fan of like
creating something that has people
asking to give you money whoever asks
first blinked that's how I think about
that let's go yeah of course have you
have you gotten remarkable at
eliminating other things besides those
two things okay good
okay how do i reaches out to me about a
speaking engagement that i can bring
just as much value from my cute pink
velvet couch in my office ring light
whatever no that's what you want it's
not what they want I mean there's
nothing I can do nope I do not believe
so
I close people paying me 185,000 to give
a speech 8,000 times easier than I pay
then I close people paying 35,000 to
simulcast it and that's consistent for
everybody it's experience there's
another thing charge more right now you
may be in the public that like if you're
willing to not travel you now have
leverage so this is like it's you
shouldn't say no you should ask for a
remarkable about more than you're
accustomed to now that's what I did when
I when I started building vaynermedia I
was like okay now I'm gonna build
vaynermedia Jess were you there did you
were you there before I was kind of
day-to-day CEO or you came right as I
was kind of there yeah so like but
what's really interesting is you know
you might have saw like vaynermedia I
guess because we formed that LLC on
April 15th even though AJ wasn't at a
school yet turned 10 but for me it's
always eight because I really didn't
operate this business the first two
years because I was busy with Wine
Library
I was really still really running that
and then I'd written crush it and the
whole garyvee thing was starting and so
when I decided in September 2011 to run
vaynermedia for real to actually be the
CEO I didn't want to speak as much
because I wanted to build a business so
I moved my fee from 5,000 to 15,000 and
what ended up happening was it was
awesome because okay
a bunch of people to say go [ __ ]
yourself you think you're a big shot
right and that was fine but some people
said yes and was like really okay
amazing and so like I don't know what
you're charging now but if you're
willing not to travel cuz you got to be
home more and whatever you're gonna find
a new remarkable thing which is you
might be able to get more that was like
one of the great I'll never forget that
year where like the year prior I spoke
like eleven or fifteen or twenty two
times and the next year I spoke like
seven but made the same money that's a
really powerful moment now
I had momentum I was like you know it's
it's a marketplace you know but yes I
mean it's fact
anytime somebody says I'm looking at
become a speaker I'm always like speak
as much as you can for as free as much
as you can
I mean look you've got your life and
like I think it's really hard I have a
lot of it's really hard for everybody
but double I've double empathy for you
know a mom because I think there's just
inherent like you birthed it this human
kind of thing I think there's and their
social and the way you know social
pressures and how you grew up in
ideologies of your grandmother's
grandmother that trickled down it's hard
to balance to begin with but it's better
than having terminal cancer you know
it's that's but it definitely feels like
that you know it's easy for you like
it's fun this pontificate you're really
thrilled right now that you do not have
terminal cancer and like that's where I
always go like like you know like like
hey it sucks that maybe you like that
you can't go 150% on the business
because you have you know parenting
obligations and wants and needs and
ambitions you could have been born in
Cambodia like and not have the same
opportunities you had at being a white
woman in America like I'm always playing
the this pisses me off but I can spend
the rest of my life talking about all
the things that are worse and I I do
believe in that perspective I don't
because you'll get crippled otherwise
you know I believe that like I think
it's I hate when dudes are like it's the
same like it's the least same thing of
all time good podcast
Bogg what are you thinking so I want to
start with video I'm a big fan of
videoing a podcast okay I'm a big fan of
it you get both film the podcast and you
we've all seen it right like Imus sports
radio does it Mike and Mike like you see
it on cable TV
it's
radio show being filmed which means it's
a TV show it it's exactly the same for
us I think my strength comes from
so you see you should do Q&A show watch
what I do not what I say when I came
back and seven years when we in 1980s so
you know this like my career has a
really funny moment in it which is when
I went double down on Boehner like mm
September 2011 to like 13 14 I was
pretty quiet for me on the Internet
there's very little like there's only
the if you look at it there's only like
the keynotes there's like a couple
things like I was very quiet and then
when I came back I was more self-aware
and what did I start the askgaryvee show
I mean I sometimes when I talked to
Caleb or anybody on my team like you
know I the breakout personality in the
business space in this last couple years
while actively being a CEO and CEO of a
massive company and when I talk to them
like could you imagine if I was just
Gary be like every morning I would do a
[ __ ] morning show from like 8 a.m. to
11 a.m. just QA and was like take you
think I'm penetrating all the channels
now it'd be over I would do it every day
it's my favorite thing to do it tea with
Gary Vee you know like nice glass of tea
just put him on call me boom boom boom
boom boom boom clip clip clip distribute
distribute every day look how pumped we
kept when we do one of the reasons I did
for these was for the [ __ ] what I
just say the firing is there like that I
don't know like it's [ __ ] good I
can't I can't wait for that piece of
content
oh the defo knowing or guessing no like
that [ __ ] thing's gonna kill on
LinkedIn that's 2 million in the bank
but I need to be asked it's hard to like
self-start
like it's not I apologize I'm really
great at self starting that's why I was
good it's just I only gonna say the same
things that I believe it the only time I
do new [ __ ] is what I'm asked that's why
I started and if you know that about
yourself make it a Q&A show right so fun
especially when you stay and you're the
biggest thing I'll tell you just stay in
your lane I think a lot of people when
they start QA have a sense of like I'm
an expert and I should have an answer
for this like it happened yesterday
I don't know right what was that I was
pumped I don't know nonetheless I'm
super pumped to tell them I'm like I
don't know I love that I'll give you a
good one though it's like nobody knows
for people out there who want to start a
Q&A show that nobody knows in the world
let's say you want to go to Twitter
search terms find questions that people
are actually asking the ethos and answer
them by like by the way that is the
actual origin story of Gary Vee nobody
in the world knew who I was when I
started Wine Library TV I went on
Twitter searched wine terms and answered
questions because I knew what I was
talking about about wine nobody knew
that I knew so you can literally if you
like you should go watch an old to
askgaryvee I clip to make the image from
the question on Twitter but you can do
that with somebody not asking you the
question John and Albuquerque asked not
me but the world saw Leatrice what
should I do when my you know what else
how much time do I have ten more minutes
okay anything else good of course
faris were going in I think it was
Titans right oh there's two
okay Timmy's a [ __ ] PC just right yes
yes Oh soft tissue work I'm doing it
right now I don't know if you notice
what I'm doing I'm literally I'm
literally doing it right now I'm
literally doing it right now okay
so I don't I don't really know but
here's what I know if you continuously
rub with a ball with your fist with a
fork on the like there is a soft tissue
there's a fashio that is built up I have
it so bad right here so I hurt my back
when I was a kid in the liquor store and
so what ended up happening was
subconsciously and I can see it in old
videos I would do this and what happened
was that became my actual posture and in
that slight Bend there's just a lot of
gunk built up here and as I've learned
to like stretch out it's still here I
mean this [ __ ] hurt and when I tell
you some of here's the craziest part
about this game right now it's like I'm
gonna show you sorry but you have to get
this look at this like I have to go
float like I'm like literally bruising
like it's what you don't know what you
don't know is how crazy this says here's
why I've now been on this for like three
years and I've only discovered that I
have more tissue stuff to do around my
like IT band here three weeks ago and
I'm like poking and prodding constantly
and you don't even your brain doesn't
want you to touch it this is real
your brain is keeping you away from it
it's this crazy gate like I feel like I
couldn't like djor I was short of us
here you're almost playing against
yourself you don't even realize it's
happening but like there's literally
places in your body right now where you
have like fashion like soft tissue
issues that you have no idea that's
happening and the second you hit it it
like blows your mind
oh my stars first of all everything was
[ __ ] up on me when I started all of it
all of it
the so ass is nuts the first you know
where it started my abductor right Mike
the first thing that ever happened
Jordans very good at soft tissue work
and he did it for baseball players
because they get a lot of gunky stuff
with it and I was doing something and
he's okay
any time and I almost jumped out of the
gym you understand you're so it's right
here it's right here right it's like in
play it's not like some weird right it's
right here I have no idea of what he's
talking about he goes huh I go like it
was so [ __ ] up so tight anyway you
know that like there's a stick that he
has that's the best the blue ball like
all this [ __ ] like it's changed my life
here's why actually I'm gonna show you
guys I think I have a picture of it this
is so crazy to me god I really hope I
have this I got to show you something
that is almost uncomfortably ridiculous
I'm gonna show you a picture yes I
showed it to you what really you have it
I think I might have it guys when I tell
you that I'm so passionate about you
guys doing this it's it changed my life
let me tell you how I sleep better when
I travel I feel better I feel better
just second to second way more than
losing weight way more than having
muscles it's changed the way I actually
walk and maneuver around life and like
you don't even it's what I'm so in tune
with myself and all this stuff but I
gotta tell you it's a it's I don't not
explain it it is should I don't have it
you have dividing it text Jordan real
quick he'll text it to you
it's something I I just found the one oh
dude it's so crazy guys
this hurts some like I'm barely touching
in between two ribs right now anyway it
like Oh God like it
so ql i don't know how educated people
are on this [ __ ] I don't even know if
I'm using the right word but there's a
cute L muscle right here and I'm like
it's still bothering me like anyway here
was what he's looking for you're gonna
see a picture of me when Jordan really
figured out the biggest issue which was
my QL I had to do this and he said ok
turn your legs like this put your hand
here
and now I want you to do this and I want
you to go this way and what you'll see
in the picture is I go like this far and
I wasn't even able to keep this hand
free I used it to brace and my face
looks like this and now what I'm able to
you know like like really able to go and
I can have my butt like this whole thing
was so tight that I wasn't able to even
move like I'm not joking like I really
can't wait for you guys to see it it's
one year exactly a part I literally was
like this like like and what's crazy is
you don't even know it like I don't know
how to explain it like you don't even
know that's because it becomes your norm
it's just I mean you found it can you
throw it you can throw it up here I'm so
pumped right now I'm so [ __ ] up still
my QL [ __ ] it hurts this new spot it's
just not dude I'm so pumped to see this
you got it yes look at this oh can you
zoom can you can you can visit words
like that guys this is look at this this
is me with all my might
trying to go to the left I'm going
nowhere hand support dead
one year later what's that I don't know
what's that no this is just but but like
one more telling like think about that
yeah and like what you don't know what
that actually means is things like I got
one when I now go for something like I
used to do this oh actually here's a
good one because how [ __ ] up I was
left to right when Jordan was like pick
up a weight and like right hand weight
over here I would just do this but when
he was like pick up that weight I would
do this
I had no range like I used to I have to
like I mandate to be on the left side of
an air of the airplane because when I
would be on the right side and try to
sleep
this wouldn't stretch like crazy [ __ ]
that you would never think about like
just it's cool it changed my life
another thing that's about to change my
life is I I'm gonna send you this do I
want you to put this up this is gonna
segue to my next thing do I ever think
I'm getting too famous yeah I won't I
can't stop it I like it too much it's
it's the good outweighs the bad and not
about and not about the selfishness of
like I like being famous it's that I
feel too good when I'm changing
somebody's life
I can't replicate the hi of somebody
emailing me and saying I was abusing
guys you don't know what I get like yeah
I have bought 43 so listen to my
heartache on this I believe that this is
the number one under car priced card in
the world now you guys all know I hate
Michael Jordan more than breathing I've
never worn a pair of Jordans I hate them
but this is the number one under priced
product in the world right now
this is a Michael Jordan rookie stick
our card not the regular card the
regular cards 5000 when it's graded a
nine like this this is how they grade
them they put them in cases and then
they give them a you can see the nine
there 10 is the best nine this this card
is selling for like a thousand I started
buying them a couple months ago when
they were 700 but I'm like driving up
the price cuz it's just drying up but I
think this card should be worth just as
much as the regular six thousand dollar
one because there's just as many made of
this as the regular one and these are
even harder to get good grades because
the stickers were even more awkward so
I'm gonna buy them all that I can
there's still I mean I have 67 or 47 I'm
gonna try to buy 500 there's probably
hundreds of thousands and then I'm gonna
tell my whole community to go and buy
them and then I'm gonna educate people
on why in supply-and-demand
normal non emotion this should equally
be worth six thousand dollars and I
think it will then go to six thousand
dollars yep you can go on eBay and you
should honestly this is you know what
back to like you know my my whole game
of like people have no money and I'm
trying to get them to get a thousand
dollars by flipping one dollar to this
this whole sports card thing the reason
I'm most passionate the number one
question I have that I do not know how
to answer which pisses me off is hey
Gary I have 18,000 dollars how should I
invest it it's a tricky number like you
know like what real estate do you buy
like Facebook Netflix stock like it's
you know this I really think that cards
are gonna go up so much and be so liquid
that a lot of people if they're really
smart and I'm gonna tell them what to
buy after I buy a little for myself I'll
be able to turn 18s into hundreds I
think somebody can easily easily it's
scary to me how realistic turning
eighteen thousand to a hundred thousand
sports cards will be over the next 18
months I really believe that garbage no
no listen I have unlimited car I've bro
I have so much garbage everything
everything you had like look
everything's garbage in that like
they're garbage but like
hakeem olajuwon bike that's a
thirty-year play I'm buying up all our
teams because I think Africa culture is
gonna be like a major I think China's
gonna be China Africa Africa is the next
continent to blow up and I think African
culture and like basketballs global and
JoEllen bead and Africa and after.look
and Hakeem is a great one like yeah I
very simply I believe in 34 years that I
will sell a ton of my Hakeem Olajuwon
rookie cards that I'm buying for 200
bucks now to African business men and
women for four thousand three things one
I think that 43 year olds are now at an
age where they have six and seven year
olds that are into it and we're playing
the nostalgia play the same reason GI
Joe and strawberry shortcake reboot
every 30 years this is what we always do
we want our kids to do what we did it's
like a thing to sneaker flipping all
these 16 17 18 year old Huck stirs
hustlers like me are in sneaker flipping
but they can't get enough supply like
when they're right they have to wait
online buy one pair and make 600 bucks
when you're right about Jordan or
giannis or Steph Curry you can buy
40,000 of them so it's the graduation
step to the kids that are doing sneakers
for the flip 3 gambling there's going to
be Zion cards one of the things that's
happening sports cards now is you can
get one of one like it's the only card
like that in the world
signature cards pieces of the Jersey
limited edition stuff
supply and demand there's only 25 of
these ions in the world there's only 25
there was a billion ken griffey jr.
rookie cards got it so soon once people
actually understand what's happening
with sports cards there's gonna be a
knowledge base even like people my
office just like that you can go into a
card store or Walmart buy an $8 pack of
prism basketball and you could pull a
$40,000 Zion rookie and unlike a lottery
ticket you could pull out the regular
Zion that's worth 25
so gambling and because of daily fantasy
and gambling people watch more sports
when they care so one of the things
people will do is like if you think like
I do like Darren the Fox is gonna be a
very good basketball player like Nick
I'm buying up a ton of Darren Fox rookie
cards right now because I think he's
like very good and next year I'm
actually gonna care what the Sacramento
Kings are doing every night because I
have financial vested interest in the
Aaron Fox is going from 14 bucks that
I'm buying them now to 40 bucks five
minutes ago I could care less if Luke
Adonis got hurt or Dallas did well
I've bought I'm buying 700 Luca rookie
cards for next year and so now I care
people like to do things to make them
care about things that's why they bet
it's not just trying to make money it's
that you all of a sudden care to watch
that playoff game tonight it enhances
the experience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]